dave chappelle has a new comedy special
out and i haven't seen it yet i guess it
just came out yesterday the day before
but i already know that i'm going to
like it based on the fact that the media
is having a hissy fit about it they're
condemning it as bigoted
incendiary all these things reckless
dangerous they're they're saying all of
the things that you should certainly
want these kinds of people to say if
you're a stand-up comedian and you've
just you know released a stand-up
special
uh so he he talks about
transgenderism which is a theme that
he's returned to
in in several of his most recent comedy
specials at one point he says that
gender is a fact and he makes a point
that um only women can have babies
and he's right about that now if i want
to split hairs here and it's not really
splitting hairs but it is important to
say uh there's no g what you mean is
biological sex is a fact gender is
actually a fiction
that uh that that
gender theory proponents and members of
the gender called have invented
um
but i get what he's saying and that's
the basic point that he's making also he
talks about the rapper uh de baby
who got into a lot of trouble recently
when he uh
made some comments about gay people
some anti-gay comments uh during a
during a concert
and people got very upset about that
and you may remember i talked about this
on my
show how the baby
uh was being criticized for these
comments he made about gay people
meanwhile you listen to any of his songs
and he's openly promoting and
encouraging people to kill each other
deal drugs all that kind of stuff
abuse women
none of that gets him in trouble
but the gay comments do
dave chappelle makes kind of that point
only he he actually brings something up
about the baby that i didn't even know
let's let's listen to this
a lot of the lgbtq community doesn't
know the baby's history he's a wild guy
he once shot
and killed him
in walmart
oh this is true google it the baby shot
and killed in walmart north carolina
nothing bad happened to his career
do you see where i'm going with this
in our country you can shoot and kill
but you better not hurt a gay person's
feelings
[Music]
so so he actually he actually killed a
guy i looked i did look that up i did
google it
per uh dave chappelle's instructions and
it's true he killed a guy in walmart
of all places and look if you cannot be
safe in a walmart then where can you be
safe
and uh you know he survived that fine
in terms of uh public relations
that was no pr crisis
but he talks about gay people and that's
a problem
now
chappelle has been accused just like
when he makes comments about gender and
in all of his previous standard specials
the left's got upset about
they always accuse him and are accusing
him again of uh of punching down
right he's this he's this wealthy
privileged guy
talking about the lgbt community this is
this is him punching down and comedians
should never punch down
well first answer to that is that
actually comedians should be their first
goal is to be funny
and so they should just be punching
wherever is the funniest to punch
okay
so it's punching up punching down as
long as it's funny you've done your job
as a comedian
but also
this is punching up
this is speaking truth to power
going after the lgbt community that is
punching up
because when a time when it comes to
cultural power
they have
all of it
so they they are the the unquestioned
untouchable authorities in in our
culture
the lgbt community is the is the the
sacred
that you cow criticize you can't say
anything about you can't make jokes
about them
you make jokes about anybody else almost
and now that also depends on where you
fall on the internet intersectional
scale dave chappelle as a black man
according to the rules of the left he
can make jokes about almost anyone else
but not lgbt because they're higher up
on the victim ladder than he is
and since victimhood is power you know
faux victimhood
is power performative victimhood is
power um
that makes the lgbt
lobby the most powerful in the country
so that that is that is speaking truth
to power that is that is an example of
punching up
not that again it really matters
when it comes to a comedian
as long as they're being funny and
that's a funny joke
that's not really a joke and i did say
that first so i'm not gonna accuse dave
chappelle of
listening to my podcast and taking my
material but hey you draw your own
conclusions if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and share it
with all your friends